[Music]
this is star talks sports edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and today we're on the
topic of genetics
and I got with me my co-host Gary
O'Reilly Gary hey Neil all right former
Soccer Pro over in the UK turned
announcer and he's sharing his time with
us
yes and I still can't stop thinking of
your wiki page a great shot of you and
with your sexy legs playing soccer
you for life
and of course Chuck nice Chucky baby how
you doing man hey Neil what's happening
all right pictures of my sexy legs and
Chuck has no Sports street cred at all
oh yeah it does oh it's a big fan fan of
sports that's enough but not no sport
without the fans very good the whole
thing is without me it doesn't exist
thank you
so Garrix
you and your producers came up with this
genetics theme so where are you going to
take us with it all right so
um it's always in the back of our mind
as to you know how do we do this how do
we make it go faster how can we make
these things better and so we landed in
the field of genetics but Sports
genetics now analyzing your own genetics
we know can give you access to your
ancestry
etc etc but what if genetic analysis
could help predict vulnerability to
certain illnesses to certain injuries
what if the data could help naturally
enhance our strength and conditioning by
tailoring specific programs of exercise
for you
now line these two things up and you're
getting what some people are dubbing
right at this moment a new money ball
right we'll get into that aspect later
on in the show we'll either explode that
theory as Buncombe or we'll embrace it
and see how we take that forward but
what you're saying is a person could be
really good at a high school or college
but I look at their genetic profile and
they have a a tendency to to to drop a
tendon uh and they so they could be on
the injury list and I don't have to pay
for that and see the thing is that
everyone's treating your injury but you
don't know that you've got in your
internal structure and exposure to
having this injury so you need to do
specific things that help
ward off that potential injury or I'm
not hiring you right I mean that oh now
we're now
in there too starting to get dangerously
closed okay it's Eugenics
okay so now you've jumped to chapter
four okay all right gotcha we're still
on the pre-face it's all there it's all
that now we're going to need someone
with some serious chops to to guide us
through this particular area and it is a
particular area with an awful lot into
it so that expert is stuck to Stuart Kim
I often remember Dr Kim's been with us
before a couple of times so we're
honored to have him back
he is considered to be one of the
world's leading experts in the genetics
of muscular skeletal injuries
former professor of genetics and
developmental biology at Stanford
University he's also co-founder and CEO
of ex-gen a sports genetics business so
uh please let's meet or meet again guys
welcome back to StarTalk thank you very
much it's a pleasure man you're you're
into some stuff here I mean who would
have thought that this is even something
that you could be an expert in a few
decades ago I just gotta just just
remind me in your background did you
grow up saying gee I want to do sport
genetics I mean how do you how do you
land where you did did you did you have
posters of Watson and Crick on your wall
Yeah well yeah exactly
um
my entire life I was a hardcore
geneticist
um so in a way Neil I think of athletes
as the new mouse
model organism yeah oh I mean the thing
is that you know for for now athletes I
know an incredible about their Phoenix
life I know how fast they are how strong
they are how tall they are
um and you know if you're professional
like Gary you know they poke and Prodigy
all these different ways which were a
scientists is just data and so for most
people I don't know very much about them
uh but for an athlete in principle I
could know and in Terror I could
interrogate all of their uh medical
records and find out what causes them to
that's it so now you're getting creepy
now
but this this is it Neil you see if I am
at the if I am the two percent off the
two percent right you know the real harm
and the Usain bolts the guys
the Brady
that's right right if I'm in that
caliber I have a need to know
and and like Stewart said we have more
data on you than we would ever have on
most people ever in the history of the
world so this is this is an amazing
amazing fact all right so so what so
where do we start here Gary what's the
first question all right so if if we
look at detection of specific markers as
kind of being the precursor to
prevention right
how long has science been able to get
into this area of analysis and identify
vulnerabilities or to be an illness or
to be an injury so how long have we been
here doctor
I would say in 2015 everything before
2015 is obsolete so in 2015
um something new happened it's really
fascinating so the Brits came along and
really paved the way uh they made this
giant Data Bank that all scientists all
over the world can can use called the UK
biobank
let me guess let me guess if it's
British they learned how to colonize the
double helix
[Laughter]
uh somewhere along the line that's going
to cost us isn't it yeah yeah yeah this
can't end well I'm pretty sure but all
right go on go on
so well I guess that started probably
around 2015 by 2017 all the scientists
lots of the scientists were accessing it
that led you
um up the ante and so now the results
started to become uh pretty serious and
significant starting around 2016-2017.
so uh by significant like a million fold
more significant than in 2015.
in 2018
um around that time scientists figured
out a new way to think about genetics
that just blew my mind and everything I
was taught about genetics
um only explains like a small fraction
of what you really want to know so
basically before before this this
revolution all the genetics is what we
call mendelian genetics mendelian
genetics is like mendels
Gene that causes a p to be wrinkled it's
it's you know it causes it can cause it
explains why some flies have white eyes
or explains
and it explains why some people have a
disease like cystic fibrosis oh what
happened in 2018 is
um
genetics has figured out something
called complex genetics and they can now
explain Heights so height isn't due to
one gene or even a small number of genes
it's a million different
changes in your genome then really dial
in your height within an inch or cell
so most of your height is genetic little
bit is you know how well you need
but now it's clear that there's
something like a million inputs into
your height each input gives you a
millimeter plus minus in your height all
right so doctor if I gave you wait wait
that means I'm I'm a million millimeters
tall
no sometimes it's minus on my other two
minus
yeah
tennis it's it's like genetic tennis
back and forth plus and minus and minus
and don't you know the uh the
statisticians and mathematicians are
going nuts and trying to figure out the
best way to add a million different
things together
all right so just to be clear what
you're saying is up until 2015 the
mendelian yeah
um understanding had to it was stuck on
the there being one gene for one effect
yeah and but we've always known that
many effects are more complex than that
are you saying that in 2018 we
figured out how to get there exactly oh
gotcha yeah the Ritz gave us the data
and then the Brits and the Australians
and a couple Americans figured out how
to analyze the data and now they can
actually through they can predict our
hype if they have a million data points
just to be clear just so we're on the
same page here statistically
for every new variable you want to to
Corral and contain yeah you need like
manifold more data to do that so yeah
right in order to contain two variables
relative to one variable and for every
add-on variable you need that much more
data and so this is all playing into
what you're saying here yeah Stuart
right yeah it's not yeah they didn't
screw up it's not overfitting right it
can really predict the height of a new
person never before seen so what methods
are we using for screening I mean I I
give you someone's genome you know
whoever it is me Chuck Neil LeBron James
yeah right so how what what method have
you is now the go-to method for your
screening because there's something
called a CGS uh candidate Gene studies
yeah and there's something I think it's
called a polygenetic risk score yeah now
what's the difference between them and
which one
came out as the best
screening process too right right the
candidate genes studies uh is this
before 2015 thing that I'm going to
argue is obsolete I'll give you an
example let's say you want to know how
strong a person is at Birth
and in the 2000s they figured out that
it was a g
um called a tenant three muscle protein
and depending on which type you had you
know it kind of
inched you towards an endurance athlete
versus our athlete the thing is that it
has an incredibly tiny effect
uh now I think it's uh of all of your
genes of all of these markers that
inform about how Enduro you know how
much endurance and power you have I
think it's number thirty thousand on the
list
so I could tell you your acting in three
genotype 23andMe will sell you your
action in information but it's number
thirty thousand on your list in terms of
the genetics of whether you're powerful
or long-lasting
um so then you know in 2015 you could do
a study and look for the most
significant genes in your genome the top
one not select 10 and 3 is number thirty
thousand 2015 you got the top one
uh and then now they have the top 175
that's where polygenic risk score comes
in and the best way to do it is to add
together all engine it's like a vote you
get all 175 of these top units and have
them all vote and together they give you
a much better idea of your muscle spray
so where does injury come in come into
this
is that risk score is that a risk of
injury what what is the risk measuring
here well I just talked about strength
so this is just how how much strain
injury is not how strong you are but you
take everybody that got hurt and
everybody that didn't get hurt and see
if there's a genetic difference and
that's that's what was done and so now
you can look at for 13 different
injuries you know you can see if they
have the marker for and these would be
the strongest markers in the genome so
there these are the kinds that are a
million times stronger than the candida
Gene study well when you need a huge
data set yes in order to make that
determination because yes there are so
many variables that go into entry itself
so this this is this is prime filled for
for AI surely there's that you must be
using algorithms all day long because
there's no there's no one individual or
a team of individuals sitting there
scouring through all of these variables
this has to be fodder for AI surely
Ai and then you know I the statisticians
are all having a they're really Paving
the way so that makes sense because
instead you what really what you want to
look at is a probability no more that
more than you know it's more of a
likelihood than anything else exactly
yeah so so you take your circumstances
you look at the likelihood and then you
change your circumstances based on that
likelihood exactly okay so who got here
first doctor Elite Sport which is
possible or general medicine because I'm
guessing that general medicine would
have been searching for these answers as
well as the elite athletes or the
organizations there yeah yeah
um well get there first is height Gary
and then once they figured out High a
heart doctor from Harvard figured out
are we going to do heart disease and now
once the heart disease doctor you know
made a really hit a really influential
publication and everybody says yeah let
me do it for my disease and so there are
hundreds thousands of polygenic risk
scores for lots and lots of different
diseases type 2 diabetes each other all
sorts of different diseases this all is
from the UK bioman it was like a gift to
scientists all across the world the
problem is that there aren't very many
Elite athletes in UK biobank what you
really wants is a lot of athletes then
we could do the genetics of athletes but
until you start to get a lot of data
it's hard to do this type of uh
statistics but did you keep the UK list
was it like an existence proof that it's
something that can be done exactly and
the UK where there was just UK athletes
or no it was UK citizens uh 500 000
people I think 600 professional athletes
so they weren't even real athletes
because they were British
so
let's let's take a specific injury risk
here so we if we look to
ACL PCL injuries yeah which is anterior
cruciate ligament posterior cruciate
ligament yeah if you're not familiar if
you've never had that kind of knee Smash
Up
um what are you looking for
um and what is it that says you know is
it ligament strength is it bone density
is it well are there other variables in
there that we really really need to be
aware of
um maybe but the first thing you do is
you just take something like an in in
this data Bank from the UK it was
something like 10 000 people who had an
ACL tear and then you take all of those
people and compare it to all the people
that didn't have an ACL there and say
What's the difference you don't have to
make any suppositions and you just come
up with right
um two G's that really that seem to be
different a little bit it's not a lot
it's not gonna you know uh but if you're
if you're a pro athlete and this is the
type of injury like an engineer totally
you know we'll sideline you for a year
at least and it might be worse yes
[Music]
um
you know and then so there you have an
incredibly valuable
commodity your your ability to perform
as an elite athlete versus a tiny effect
on a small effect on whether or not
you're going to get it but it's still I
it still were
um integrating that into your training
regimen since we do wouldn't it benefit
me not even from a genetic standpoint
couldn't I achieve almost the same thing
by creating a data set where uh because
every thing is filmed now everything
where I just looked at every single ACL
injury yeah and then every single
circumstance where an ACL in that very
similar circumstance did not tear and
wouldn't I be able to deduce you know
some best practices uh from from that
data set
um
well that's been done I mean uh you know
people look and I'm in the wrong damn
business
right so there's the God there's a
there's a training regimen well known
it's called this FIFA 11 plus I think
and so you know the trainers all tell
mostly soccer players on how to not get
an ACL doctor FIFA being the
International Football Association so
the world governing body so is everybody
sort of works out what their acronyms
right right
um
so chuck if you look I mean if you look
at an athlete and you see how they move
that's a lot of information that's
really strong at predicting and you know
there are some organizations around that
are really good at this and they they
put the biosensis up and down the
athletes and they say you know are you
jumping when you jump do you land on one
foot or do you land money and you say
that's really bad they can train
um basketball players and volleyball
players how to how to jump yeah okay so
on I'm talking about DNA and I just want
to know when you were born is there
something about how your femur and how
your ligaments are all
attached so it's everything we can see
right with the naked eye or with this
high speed cameras that we can use now
in terms of your Technique I jump I land
in a certain way if I don't land in a
certain way well guess what ankles knees
hips everything structurally is going to
have an issue that's okay I might have
the 10 out of 10 perfect Nadia common
Edge technique
but if it's going wrong inside where we
can't see I'm getting
problems I am going to get compound
problem after problem after problem and
there's nothing you can be solved it's
because I'm always getting torn up from
the inside out not the outside in and
that that kind of makes sense like okay
this is anecdotal uh and I'm not sure if
it applies at all but Dr Kim you can
tell me so uh I had a root canal done on
my front left tooth my father had a root
canal done on his front left tooth his
father had a root canal
now I'm thinking like what Gary just
said like you know maybe that's
coincidence or maybe that's one of these
things where there might be a genetic
marker no no there are certain it was
the same dentist it was the only surgery
he knew how to do
you guys think how to take a quick break
look at Neil Neil's on fire today
what is oh
come on my Netflix special is coming out
no no
no so we take a quick break we're gonna
find out how much this genetics uh my
knowledge of its genetics can be
exploited to boost our own performance
and whatever it is we do when StarTalk
sports edition returns with Dr Stuart
Kim
we're back StarTalk sports edition this
is an entire episode on genetics with a
genetics expert Dr Stewart Kim and
Stuart what is the
either the ethics or before we get to
the ethics how much are people invoking
your data your analysis your knowledge
of their genetics to
I enhance their performance in ways that
they could not have otherwise done
without that information
well that's a great question
um
my feeling is it's hard to need a
stopwatch
so I don't think it's hard for genetics
to be
what
Gary already knows about how fast and
how strong he is
so I've tried hard to find something
about genetics that would tell you but
you know these athletes know exactly how
fast they are they know exactly how much
weight they can lift and not only that
but they're already chewing their vents
to be fast and strong
though it's kind of not easy for
genetics to really add in that Arena
what what you don't know at all is where
you're going to get hurt you don't know
if you're going if you're liable for
shoulder injury
um which a soccer player doesn't care
about blood and knee injury or ankle
injury and if you could know if you were
you know if you had a knee injury issue
you know you might want to try to train
that down so that you're less likely to
get a neogene uh so that's it's easier
to okay but that's it's one thing to
just not
mess up do all you can to not die and do
all you can to not break but I'm talking
about I'm completely healthy and I want
to use your information to break my own
record is there something you can tell
me that can make that happen for example
is it something as prosaic as does my
chemistry differ from yours in how I
metabolize sugar to draw energy from it
or and or is that just something I train
to do rather than was born with the
genetics to enable
well there's lots of theory
theoretically possible there so in
principle we could there could be
information today you know I'm trying
hard to to try to uh to find an instance
you know the best example but it only
affects a few people in Finland is Euro
montiranga wow oh yeah Gary you know
about this guy so yeah he was uh Finnish
cross-country skier he was the world's
best but he won you know Olympic medals
World Championships by a lot
and then Along Comes The anti-doping
Association who took a look at him and
said you must be Dopey because nobody
has
um red blood cells as much as you do and
athletes try their hardest to get a lot
of red blood cells because it helps you
ski oxygen you know bicyclists try hard
to get uh either
you know some of them cheat to try and
be able to uh ride a long time yeah
yeah well you wrote gut you know accused
of blood doping and he said no no no I
don't what I don't know and finally it
was another a British geneticist came to
the game to his rescue
um and he found out that Euro had a
mutation a natural mutation one was born
with when his mom and his dad that
activated something called an EPO
receptor so the dopers give inject Depot
ero had
always turned on the eporeceptor so it's
always a zip he had an EPO in his blood
and so his stem cells were making red
blood cells to the mass and he became
world champion
so that's that's one example where if
you were born with Euros mutation I
would say just go for something where
you know climb Mount Everest
fight about you know Tour de France and
and cross country speak because you have
a really good chance of being good at it
wait wait but wait so maybe we can save
this for section three Gary you tell me
but let me just ask
that means he's genetically cheating
because he's not on the he's not on the
level playing field with the other
competitors so so so so therefore let me
dope my blood so that it does what his
blood does and that way we got apples
and apples here and and it's we have a
Level Playing Field no there's nothing
it's not level it's not level if if this
is a naturally occurring situation it's
like someone who's born and all of a
sudden they develop this man I'm telling
you Stuart Kim has knowledge of genetics
that in the future I'm going to say I
want to be cross-country skier Champion
give me this genetic anomaly
in utero
that's a different thing all together
Neil when when you're looking at someone
who is born with as someone who has then
gone away and gone you know what this is
exactly this is my shopping list what if
you're born with because someone put it
there thank you
it's not just a random occurrence
someone put it there now you're born
with it right this becomes this becomes
a a doping program in utro obviously but
this is this is genetics oh the Russians
will do it the Russells are going to do
it because this is engineering we are
we're in the field of engineering it's I
mean it's different Neil to the point
you were making earlier on where you
know all I'm trying to do is stay alive
which in sporting terms is all I'm
trying to do is perform at my best you
see I might be training in a certain way
in terms of developing certain muscle
strength in a certain way which once I
go to someone like Dr Kim's organization
says to me you know what that's
detrimental you've got an exposure to
this kind of injury where this is
debilitating this it's taking away you
need to strengthen certain areas this
strengthening muscle strengthening hips
and it might be muscles around your hips
that align the way that you actually run
on your gate something along those lines
that then gives you that ability now
what you're saying here if you go in
utro and start to change these things
then well this is malice or four thought
this is I'm just trying to be blunt here
no that's fine I get it if you come out
genetically different from me that gives
you an advantage that's not a Level
Playing Field and and and the whole
point of anti-doping laws is so that
everyone is on a Level Playing Field
because people are naturally born with
like hero the the Nordic cross-country
skier who are naturally born with this
going on they've not gone out of their
way to have it engineered so the the pla
the playing field is as level as
possible but it's never going to be
there you never then what you're saying
is you're you're projecting a future and
let me get we're talking I want to we
got Stuart here to talk about yeah let's
do it yeah let's do it let's do it
please yeah jump in because my knowledge
is minimal yeah so the point is what
you're saying in the limit of this
every winner of every sport is going to
be a genetic freak
with genetic profile
that favors their performance in that
event relative to everyone else and so
we're cheering genetics not hard work
not uh oh because they grew up in a way
and they ran the you know up the
mountain to to go to school and it's in
no we're just it's the genetic freak
Olympics that's what you're telling me
in the limit here Stuart is that what
the future of this is
um
I don't think that's exactly so it's
it's every it's part
um I'm exaggerating of course
like his mutation is in all of his in
his relatives so his sisters and his
brothers have the same mutation Euro won
the gold medals that's because he was
out eating all the time so it's part how
you train in part how you were born
um
and then part of it is this this erode
thing I brought up because it's this
mendelian type I think most of it
athleticism is going to be this complex
life so if you want to ask about why is
LeBron so great I think it might be a
million inputs about what makes him
great not just one mutation
and then uh genoves doesn't believe all
people are created equal and so when a
sports geneticist will just point out
that there's got to be differences based
on your ethnicity so Asians
African-Americans Caucasians you know
we're not created equal and there was
nothing I could ever do in training that
would let me play in the NBA
uh
me neither yeah so but but I don't have
the uh you could oh you could
to my mind having been a professional
athlete and I've been around all
different shapes and sizes in my own
particular sport I'm going you know what
you don't look like you're the kind of
identity shape to be an elite soccer
player yeah yeah it looks messy you
surprised me you know and then it and so
this thing is okay so you you've got the
ideal body shape you've got technique
that is mind-boggling
yeah you drink all night and you smoke
60 cigarettes a day you still gotta want
to do it right and then so so it becomes
environmental then it becomes a mental
thing the dangerous space is the bit
between your ears yeah it goes on in
there that allows you I mean there's all
there's this kind of sort of urban myth
that there's probably sprinters in
Jamaica that are faster than Usain Bolt
they just never got into the program so
all right so let me just bring some
Focus to this so
yes every human is unique genetically
unique no one is disputing that we uh
and we have
um no end of systems in place in society
to sort US based on some ability or
talent and in any meritocracy this is
foundational in how they work so no one
is arguing that what I just wonder is
what is the value of you to say
you have to go up to someone you have
the genetics to be a world-class
whatever
and then the person says well I don't
feel like it I want to you know no yeah
I want to read yeah so then what what
good are you what what is the value of
your advice here are you so in other
words you're going to tell people you
should or shouldn't do something in
their lives if they want to excel in the
way you think they will I heard long ago
a geneticist is someone who tells you
why you look like your parents and if
you don't they tell you why you should
have looked like your parents right yeah
and so this is so so what good are you I
don't need you it's my ambition between
me and what I want to achieve then it
becomes personal new I mean I've been
around a lot of guys growing up who were
so talented silly talented they never
got into a professional system even
through the academies for example right
so so what are you going to run after
them and say you should do this because
personal choice personal choice yeah and
you look at it and go wait thank you you
run after them and you tell of them this
is why your father never loved you see
look at that dream look at what you're
doing you look at how you are just
wasting all of them
this is why your dad hates you
I think I said this last time you were
on my father in gym class in high school
was pointed out by the gym instructor
when they were transitioning to this the
the track and field unit and my he
pointed out said Cyril Tyson for example
has the kind of body that would never
excel at track
and my father heard that and he said no
one is going to tell me what I cannot do
in my life yeah
so on that day he took up running and
and he became world class with the fifth
fastest time in the world in his event a
middle distance rent and so I'm just so
I'm just wondering
what why do we need geneticists if all
you're going to do is tell me what I
should do and if I don't do it you tell
me why I should have done it and you're
not measuring my ambition see people now
are coming along and they are data
hungry they want to know they need to
know you think about all of the things
people access in terms of information
about themselves now not just ancestry
they want to know about this they want
to know about that they want to be able
to do this they want to do that and now
all of a sudden you know what what is my
tolerance for caffeine am I that sort of
person that can metabolize caffeine
quickly or slowly am I the sort of
person that you know what needs vitamin
B12 but you know what I don't have a
really good capacity to metabolize that
quickly I need to know that so people
want this information people no they're
not just there to be elite athletes this
is therefore General consumption of
understanding of okay okay an intimate
self yeah but if so but what I'm saying
is if if you're going to use the
genetics to sort people not just to show
that we're different because we know
that it's just we get more detail for
why we're different we're going to do it
to sort people for who's going to get
access to opportunity and who is not and
in that equation is not their ambition
to achieve then that's Dane that's like
Eugenics at that level so so so Stuart
getting back to
Chuck's earlier point
are are you skirting the line
between sort of moral invocation of
genetics and what the you genetic what
the Eugenics folks did a century ago
uh
no and you know
everybody but me is is an elite athlete
so we're all players sentient you know
the simple idea is to help them not get
hurt so they get to they get to win more
and they get the better career at the
end of the day wow that's interesting
that you say that because what you're
saying is what you're dealing with are
people who already made it to it exactly
exactly exactly yeah it has nothing to
do with what what a choice starting from
scratch starting from scratch they're
already there got it they're already and
the thing is Chuck they want to stay
there I remember listening to a radio
interview with Olympic gold medal long
jumper right
and he obviously wasn't bad at jumping
into the sand from a long distance away
however he went to a university in the
US and I do not remember which one it
was and investigated his own self
through the genetics because Long John
the pounds per square inch through your
thing when you're Landing the sprinting
everything about you so he needed to go
away and find that information so as he
could train better because it's all
about sprinting okay so he needed to
improve his Sprint and therefore were
there were there ways for him to train
and develop so as he could actually gain
that extra bit and stay at the very top
of long jump so yes it is Elite athletes
who wish to stay Elite it is these guys
that you know what they want to extend
the bell curve of their career they
don't want a Mount Everest Peak they
want a nice long Plateau before it sort
of just tapers away so and I don't know
we think we'll get into this in the next
section but I think you know maybe the
Doctors Care will Enlighten us
up athletes like LeBron are athletes
like Chuck's friend Tom Brady who may or
may not have retired friendship
um are they the Vanguard
of where athletes are going now in the
future or are these just you know what
these are outliers dude these guys just
come around they're like hence teeth you
know we see them every so often but not
very often all right so we're going to
take a break and when we come back we're
gonna see how uh Dr Stuart Kim's
expertise might just be adopted into
Better Living
through the knowledge of our genetics
when we start talking sports edition
returns
we're back the third and final segment
uh star talk sports edition genetics
with Dr Stuart Kim who specializes in
how understanding your genetics can
change how you live and what you do and
improve your
risks of injury or reduce your risk of
injury in whatever is your walk in life
and in this segment we just want to ask
whether Stewart whether your knowledge a
person's knowledge of their own genetic
profile how can they take that into
their Twilight years either as an
athlete prolonging their their how long
they can be at the top of their game or
in their game at all or for the rest of
us who just want to live a long healthy
life well
there is the hero project let me tell
you about the hero project athletes are
at really one end of the of a
distribution they're they're faster
they're they're stronger so our uh
cross-country Runners our endurance
Runners they're thin they will never be
obese they will not get type 2 diabetes
our NFL players will not yet weak muscle
disease called sarpopedia and so there's
diseases like you know all of us are
worrying about putting on weight and
type 2 diabetes or losing our strength
as we get older and here are the
athletes might have clues about how they
were so strong uh and some of these
endurance Runners we know they they eat
6 000 calories a day and they cannot put
on weight and it's not just because
they're running so so much but what if
we could learn from them and figure out
either mental or physical what is it
that lets you stay so again or dial in
your way to within a pound I mean what
if we all had the mental fortitude to
control our diet like Tom Brady so that
I mean there's no way I could I could
you know be that kind of regimen but
busy can stick to you know his his
regimen and and that's because he he
rightfully hates himself and so that's
why he's able to do this thank you Chuck
for your Tom Brady analysis Tom Brady
hate himself
what more could that guy want that he
doesn't have oh that's the whole point
he's totally over compensating for his
self-hatred and self-loathing so okay we
we said at the top of the show Dr Kim
about you know what people are calling
this kind of area where you've got
injury and illness potentially being
able to be detected in advance of it
happening because of something that's
going on in your genes and then you know
what we're in we're analyzing foodstuffs
and Lifestyles and environments that may
impact upon you as an individual and how
this could be the new money ball for
sports organizations for athletes
themselves is that just a full storm or
is is this actually got a legitimate
back up to to it being the new level and
new generation of Analytics
well in Moneyball
um
the Oakland A's in 2001 said they had a
different way of evaluating athletes not
just not you know
um
rdis and averages they said you know
they came up with all these other stats
and they tried to find Value how to
evaluate a player that wasn't in the
traditional stats and so I think
genetics is a way that you could
evaluate people with a new kind of stats
and it could give you an edge uh one way
or another uh in this case you know the
edge would be did not get hurt so you
play more games and win more games that
makes sense I mean you're not looking at
it it's it's it's really because when
you look at those markers it doesn't
mean that it's going to happen exactly
it means that it's far more likely to
happen exactly so if you start taking
preventative measures to keep it from
happening then you're ahead of the game
right that's yeah it's that simple this
is the LeBron Brady scenario I mean
they've they've tapped into this
situation where they've gone you know
what if they've done this analysis and
that the data's come back and they've
gone all right I need to work this way
and I need to to be able to do this I
mean the great thing is we've always
said it knowledge is power
now
who has control of this power we we know
the athlete will know their own profile
and how they can possibly go about
working developing training
strengthening and conditioning
but what if the coach has this power
what if the coach goes you know what he
he's crucial ligaments could explode at
any moment
um I've been not playing but you know
what trade him and this this becomes an
ethical situation you know who's allowed
to
keep this data how much of this data can
get out because it's it's personal this
becomes a data protection issue
so it's short Stuart is do you have an
ethicist in your lab looking over your
shoulder that's what this comes down to
uh
not in my lab but you know I have
lawyers
and are writing the ethics I mean this
is a incredibly important point you know
it's it's genetic discrimination so for
normal people you know why I have a law
that says my genes and prevent my
insurance company if I'm insuring me so
it's called the genetic information
non-discrimination act
so we need the same thing for athletes
we need something that you know your DNA
cannot let your the owners discriminate
against you and your contract and then
it's still a good idea because everybody
wins the owner should like this because
their players if they have their coaches
and trainers have this information and
in principle they could train the
players in a smarter way and the players
would get so correct and then they would
have to pay for injured players they
would win more their team would be up in
value the owners are going to win
anyways they don't have to screw around
with contracts and so there's a way to
set this up just like our health care is
set up that there's no discrimination in
professional sports and that's only for
team sports with owners so the tennis
players should love this and you know
they should know about shoulder injuries
and knee injuries okay so we're at this
point now and you've got ahead of the
game in terms of you know what we need
to protect genetic profiles etc etc
where are we gonna go with this moving
forward I mean are we done now I mean if
this this bio Bank guarded by corgis and
butlers in the UK with a very very
Crystal cut accent sounds fabulous but
um where do we where do we go what
because I can't imagine people said oh
that's we've learned enough now that's
not that's not how this works so what
are we going to get exposed to what are
people going to be looking for in the
future plus Brady and LeBron were aren't
they each over 40
no braid is 45 oh old I believe yes
bronny's ancient he's 38. oh he's only
38 okay but yeah but still I mean so
we're talking about bringing this into
our Twilight ears yeah so what's what's
what's what does the research say Brady
and LeBron that we want to think about
it's a guy named Robert Griffin the
third you remember him yeah he was a
superstar agree RG3 he was a superstar
quarterback and he tore up his knee in
his first year he never heard of him so
it's like it's like you're with like a
Tom Brady to be but he he got hurt I
mean you know he's not he never had a
professional career so it's really for
all of the best that never were that
we're trying to we're trying to work
with Wow Tom Brady didn't get hurt
mostly and LeBron had a successful
career but what if they got hurt in
college or high school and never got us
you know never got a scholarship you
never would have heard of him so high
schools looking at this kind of
analytics and using it for their their
athletes and we're seeing this at
college level as well
uh not yet I mean this is brand new and
it's going to take a while for it to uh
filter down but you know the younger you
get the more useful this is like you
know if you were a high school athlete
want to be and you said who knows what
my upper end is going to be I could make
it into the Premier League but only if
you don't get hurt wow yeah the younger
you are the more potential you have to
protect and then you know doing this
training or that training you if you had
a personalized training regimen from
Young that would optimize your chance of
staying injury free at least you have a
chance to go as far as you want you you
could go in your in your professional
career
if you sort of found this program at the
age 28 29 what you'll have to do first
is undo all of the bad stuff you've done
prior yeah right and rather than tapping
into this it's sort of like 15 16 years
of age and gone you know what
I'm still growing but we can work with
that we can build in all of the good
stuff that will protect me going forward
and enable me to have a potentially
better career if that's what it is I
want to do because as I said before you
know what I might turn around and go
yeah I'm gonna walk away and do
something else but there's another side
of this by the way uh we've had Lindsey
Vonn as a guest on the star talk sports
edition and I was just dumbstruck when
she described that she took a spill on
one of her downhill races and had to be
airlifted off the side of the mountain
was taken to the hospital and she said I
I'm I don't want to lose any time in
this tournament or whatever they call
them and she I don't know what she they
taped her up or something and she was
skiing again the next day and I'm trying
to think to myself Beyond injury there
is the drive right where you don't just
you know I got a broken bone just tape
you know
whatever doctors use and then you go
back out and there's a whole other
mental state can you genetically code
for mental States
you can't you know one of the most
there's all sorts of and made Fairly
controversial studies there's genetics
or
um
they call it educational attainment so
they take everybody they have the PHD
compared to everybody else and they can
find the genes for that
um and
you know and it's kind of controversial
about whether at Birth you can figure
out what your what Your you know
educational attainment could be
and
yeah so this is like a temperament it's
kind of like a temperament for one thing
versus another in a sense right
yeah it's you know from the athletes
saying no it's clear they have a
different peppermint they you know they
can just control their whims and urges
and things so that they can you know
they can get out and do this exercise
every day they can control their diet
they can really sculpt themselves in a
way I cannot see the thing is great yeah
there is Angela what's her name Andrew
Duckworth the doctor we had on talking
about grit yeah the coach can work with
you the strength and conditioning guys
can work with you all of that side of
the sport can be can be controlled to a
certain extent
I don't know when that athlete walks
into the stadium
what's going on in here yeah as the
coach am I gonna get game ready Gary or
Amana gonna get Gary who's got six
girlfriends a problem in over there and
this there and they're all arguing
they're all going to turn up to the game
and I've got to try and put them all in
different boxes
I came up with that example way too easy
getting ready Gary uh lost out to horny
giddy Gary so this is this is the thing
right
my my head's not in my game my head's
somewhere else it might be a business
that I've got back you know somewhere
that's failing so that's now you know
there's something there's a lawsuit
going on it could be a number of things
right so all of a sudden if I can have
that kind of alchemy as a coach to know
you know what this guy's going to be
predisposed to going AWOL now sometimes
you know from behavior that you have
observed during Camp during training
during games that certain players
certain athletes are gonna be a little
bit more vulnerable that's just yeah
you're being a parent your parents
totally at that level yeah but you know
if you can get into that point where you
can you know apart from with what we can
see visually from an athlete go back to
the jumping scenario that might be
perfect but the stuff that's going on
inside we can't see that's the stuff
that's really scary yeah but I'm I'm
sorry there's I'm sure there's something
that that you can uh quantify there to
like holding faster Focus well I'm
getting there I'm getting there so
Stuart if take us into the future so
obviously height is a very measurable
thing that where there's no ambiguity
what it means how to measure it and
you've got your genetic factors that
contribute to it
part of what we're describing here is a
person's Drive such as what my father
exhibited when he said he was told he
couldn't run what Lindsey Vaughn
exhibited when she was airlifted off the
mountain and returned the next day there
there are people who have focus is there
a future of genetic
uh genetic knowledge
that can tell you about a person's
uh personality the person's motives a
person's morality a person any of this
and if there is
what kind of future is that that then I
now I fear you
yeah Power that you'll have over us all
hello
where there's a lot packed into that
meal I mean part of what you're asking
is
uh is knowledge always power or is it
always gonna sometimes being evil that's
one question
the other thing about these things is if
you can quantify it and you can get
enough people into a databank we you
know Genesis can know it so let's
imagine you quantify draw in in
everything and it's not just athlete
child to be able I mean these athletes
are incredibly driven uh yeah long every
everyone that's a long distance Runner
has has a drive to just get up and
exercise but it could be Oscar
businesses you know they need a drive to
make it through that or you know to make
it to be
and all these different everywhere you
could quantify drive and you could take
everybody with a lot of drivers since
everybody didn't have a lot of Joy
eventually if you had enough people
you'd be able to figure out the DNA that
gave some people an inherently more
drugs and then and then the other part
is going to be parenting how much you
know how much your parents influenced
your job but you can know it well what
about this let's say I were able to
create some kind of biological surgery
okay where I could restore anyone to
perfect health uh using whatever some
type of cellular manipulation right so I
can go in I can rebuild an E I can do
whatever like that with that eliminate
the need to know the information that
we're talking about right now
well I think you'd want to know what you
at or at and then that would tell you
how you could change it you know there's
this new Gene editing technology that's
coming up that's where I was going next
yeah and so now that's where I can't do
it but in the future you could right you
know change your DNA you could
um you know change your EPO receptor to
look like you romantic Rock and then go
running
um and it's not gonna make you a
world-class skier but it's going to get
you a lot closer it's going to give you
potential you didn't used to have yeah
and then that's what these mendelian
things it's got to be where I don't know
what you would do if it's a million
things that's the difference between us
and Tom Brady I don't know how you would
change your DNA but the difference
between Austin Euro Monte rocking is one
nucleotide and so you just have to go in
and change that one thing put one in
yeah it's literally cut and paste cut in
paste and we know exactly you know oh
Stuart did you did you
create your kids
[Laughter]
he's my kid okay I was letting you
answer that in whatever way you felt
that what you were comfortable
all right so this is clearly as Thomas
Huxley once said A Brave New World yeah
um on a whole other level yeah with this
knowledge of genetics and I think we
have enough
historical cautions on the on route to
just keep an eye on this because humans
if they get the chance will sort you in
such a way that
oppression follows immediately after
this is the Nazis did it the the you
know the eugenesis did it the
Anthropologist did it the European
anthropology so so yeah it's it's got a
really ugly past and so one would have
to tread carefully here I think to not
repeat the errors of the ways of our uh
I think the past is ugly because we're
ugly so you know if yeah yeah and it
means we're capable of doing it again
again that's right yeah right that's
right but we will note Stuart that if
your kids start winning cross-country
tournaments and thanks I have nothing to
do with it
we got an eye on you Stuart
why does your son run as fast as that
kid in The Incredibles movie
[Laughter]
all right we got to end it there Stuart
great to have you back on start thank
you so much we love finding out all
these inroads onto what it is we talk
about and how it could be influenced now
and in the future all right Chuck always
good to see you always a pleasure all
right Gary thank you you've been
listening to and possibly even watching
StarTalk sports edition all about
genetics with our friend Dr Stewart Kim
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
looking up
[Music]